you know for a lot of us the world can
feel like a really chaotic place there's
so many things happening all over the
world all at once and with cable news
and the internet and social media we
have access to all of it and while there
are a lot of good things peered in there
so much of the information we get can
feel big and heavy and weighty which is
why for many of us the preferred way to
consume information about the world is
with a dose of humor well our guest
today specializes in just that he is a
comedian he's an actor he's a journalist
and he's an Emmy nominated producer
please welcome Roy Wood Jr thank you
Chris how you doing I'm doing great well
Roy you know a lot of people know you as
a comedian who sometimes plays a
journalist on TV but you actually do
speaking of your academic background you
actually do have a background in
journalism both in terms of your lineage
your your father was a legendary
journalist and your own education can
you um to start us off maybe tell us
more about that back and how it
influences the way you define yourself
as a comedian and also as a Storyteller
I I grew up you know my father was a
civil rights journalist my father if it
was black and it was Strife he was
embedded there so we're going all the
way back to soo riots he got shot at by
snipers he was embedded in
Vietnam uh with predominantly black
platoon he was part of the Civil Rights
Movement he was in rhia now Zimbabwe
covering that Civil War so you know my
father has always been a person that has
just always tried to find what's wrong
and at least be a bullhorn for what was
happening and so I grew up watching the
local news every night my dad watch the
local news and yell at the my dad would
yell at the news the way people yell at
football like the I'm not going to sit
here and act like this is the family
business I mean I have a lot of
journalists in my family but I wanted to
be a firefighter man I wanted to be a
fire fighter and then I saw Stuart Scott
and I wanted to do Sports I wanted to be
funny I wanted to be Jenny moose I
wanted to be Kenny Maine you know that
that's those are the people that I
looked up to and then once somewhere I
got into my 30s I caught myself yelling
at the
television and I just like ah time to
change my comedy well it is true right
like so much of Comedy comes from some
frustration with the things that are
happening in the world often in a really
small like insignificant way but it
comes from that same H why is it like
this you know question that other people
don't seem to be paying attention to
often yeah and I think that was part of
the shift to journalism and and then
just what happened is that as I when I
started I started standing up when I was
19 so I didn't really have a lot to say
all my jokes were about book buyback and
your roommate eating your food just but
once I turned that corner around my late
20s into my early 30s I started taking a
little bit of a more journalistic
approach to like what we were taught at
Florida A&M was what is the thing you
can say about this topic that hasn't
been said yet or that you wish could be
said and so that became kind of the same
North Star for me comedically and I mean
honestly to me comedy is journalism it's
just you're just reporting on either
what's happening to you personally or
what's happening to all of us
collectively it's not that different you
know and I think once you're once you're
in a truthful space then you have an
opportunity to to truly connect with
people and you know like that's just
what it's been like I wish I could tell
you that this was some deliberate Arc
from when I was the first time I saw
Sinbad on the HBO free preview weekend
in the '90s and like no I just I enjoyed
getting up in a room full of strangers
and just trying to accepting the
challenge of trying to make them laugh
and the things that became of Worth to
me became very important and then I had
a child and then it became very serious
about okay well what am I trying to say
what the hell am I talking about let's
actually try and let's structure
something here yeah I I'd love to talk
to you about that because you know
Father Figure and imperfect messenger
two of your comedy specials which are
two of my favorite comedy specials of
all time they they both open with you
talking to your son so how how did
having a kid change the way that you
think about comedy and change maybe the
responsibility of having a platform and
people paying attention to you A lot of
it if I'm being honest it's just me
leaving Breck crumbs of knowledge for
him for when he's older in case I'm not
here that's really a lot of what it of
what it is you know it's me
having it's the general public getting
to witness me leave messages to my
child that's kind of what my career
starting to turn into and I'm perfectly
fine with that and it's not from a play
and I don't say that in some morbid
sense of die tomorrow but it is
essentially important to me to make sure
that the lessons and my father died when
I was 16 and I think that's also part of
why I'm wired like this now because
there are certain lessons and things
that I just wasn't we weren't wasn't
time for those conversations when I was
a teenager so the things that I really
hope that he understands about himself
in the world let me start putting that
stuff out there in the world now
comedically a little bit and I just
think infusing him just a little bit
kind of creates that through line of you
know who it is I'm actually talking to
without it being you know nail on the
head you know there's just certain you
know it it's also part of why I'm my
standup I don't talk at least I try not
to talk about specific people you know
in part of that because you know for
seven years on The Daily Show that's
what we do we talk about people and I
want to talk about issues and feelings
because the issues will tend to still be
there as the people affecting or
disaffect those issues come and go it's
always a the the the people trying to
change the isues are revolving door but
the issue Remains the issue so there's a
question from one of the audience
members Susan and I think this really
relates exactly to what you're saying
which is how can you use humor as a tool
to bring up those difficult issues or
questions I think that it's about
figuring out a way to find the common
denominator between people so so when I
started doing standup again as a
teenager if you're trying to do comedy
every week in the South and I'm from
Birmingham I was in school in
Tallahassee so those are my two comedy
bases but if you're in buxy you're at
the casinos performing for retirees if
you're in Florida down on the Lower East
Coast it's l it's Latino heavy redneck
heavy on the Gul Coast side you could be
doing an urban night in Atlanta you
could be doing a mainstream night in
Nashville so what I started what I hated
was always having to change up my jokes
and change up everything
whereas if I could figure out the things
that connect us then I'd never have to
change no matter where I am like you can
find certain topics that and I don't
mean that from a divisive versus non-
divisive place but I just mean it for
the things that we're passionate about
if you start in a general place you know
it's food it's love it's entertainment
and some sort of form of employment or
provision making money the thing that
emotionally fulfills you right so what I
what I what I started doing was trying
to do material that was rooted in one of
those things we all love a food we all
desire emotion or have experienced
heartbreak we all desire even if it's
not employment if you just want to go
hike what's the thing you want so if I
share my emotion and my passion for
something then in theory these people
should be connected with me because they
have a similar one
so if you find a way to connect people
in the beginning of a conversation then
they are more open to receiving humor
you know like it's it's not you you
can't just joke joke joke joke joke you
have to come in from some level and
degree of understanding you know I think
that for as long as people understand
your intentions then humor is not the
tight rope that we think it to be you
know especially when people are starting
out in comedy they they try and make
these really General jokes that are are
often kind of overwritten or overthought
and I find that often the things that
make people laugh the most are just the
most honest the the truest thing you can
say the most vulnerable yeah yeah and
that's a big that at least for me that
has been a big Revelation in in on stage
is to realize like you can bring your
full self and uh that thing that you're
so worried about sharing actually is
what other people want to hear and will
connect with the most and so now
a joke the best jokes land in one of two
places it's either the audience absorbs
it as wow I didn't know that or I didn't
look at it like that or it's that's what
I've been trying to say yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so if you if you hit either of
those
nerves then anything you do after that
the people they're
all uhhuh you get up in front of a
boring room and you acknowledge hey yeah
I know this is boring let's hurry up and
let's let's go let's do it like if you
acknowledge the obvious so I spoke at
the National Association of black
journalists conference in Birmingham
earlier this year and it's an average 1M
fluorescent
light stage Circle T I call it Circle
table events the circle table banquet
whatever right a challenge yes but which
and it's gigs like that that prepared me
for the White House cour responded which
I want to talk about you do 20 years of
circle tables you're ready for the DC
Circle table the Super Bowl of circle
tables but at that event the first thing
I acknowledged was yeah thank you all
for coming to Birmingham I know it sucks
because there's no Uber black which is a
true statement Birmingham my hometown I
can say this Uber X is a 20 minute wait
and if you're coming from LA or if
you're coming from a five minute Uber
City then that's a tough thing to to
stomach and deal with um so you
acknowledge that and then you're able to
get into things that are a little
tougher and a little harder uh to digest
and often things that a lot of people
don't want to laugh at or do not find
funny yeah lordis in Mexico is saying
that uh comedy is is underrated around
the world but it's truly a tool for
mental health and I I really agree in
the sense too that like something that
I've always admired about your comedy
from the first time that I saw you is
that you are able to talk about really
heavy serious stuff in a way that's
hilarious but you're also not afraid to
talk about the light you know just goofy
absurd stuff too you you have a mix of
both and and that's such a joy to watch
on stage
comedians because we are of this craft
we are a little
more I don't know if encrusted is the
word I don't know it's not salmon but
we're hardened calcified there you go
we're galvanized emotionally so things
don't hit us as hard right away it's
just funny to me and it's just it's
weird and it's observ like I I've been
talking about on stage to mixed reviews
that I know white people are going
through stuff because they're showing up
you know in full fatigue to protest at
Disney world like it's 90 degrees bro
there's better attire you want to
protest Pro like say what you want about
the clan but at least the robe was nice
and breathable and so that's
it feels Pro Clan but it's not it's Pro
so it's it's it's stuff like that where
you make that joke now we can get into
the deeper topic of white supremacy and
now we can get into something a little
more weird because we've made the kind
of weird obvious joke that you would
have never thought about but like oh
yeah the clan yeah they never did they
they wore loose stuff because they
didn't want to die of heat stroke
so it's fun to me it's fun to find those
lines and those edges there's a question
from Gretchen that I think is is a
really important one which is when we're
talking about creating those under that
understanding of your intentions how do
you create that understanding with the
audience when you're making a joke that
is on on the line or that could be kind
of interpreted in different ways because
it does seem like many
times there's a risk of people kind of
filling in the blanks and and thinking
uh you know as Gretchen put it that
there could be a simplistic assumption
about you as a person based on your
gender age residence political
affiliation so how do you how do you get
to the real understanding of what your
actual intention is with the audience uh
I think that comes just in time with
within the duration of the performance
so you know one thing for me that I have
to work on and a lot of this this goes
back to psychology I used to watch this
show on N Geo called brain
games and the they they brought it back
in a couple different iterations now
it's more of a game showy thing now with
Keegan with um Keegan Michael ke but in
the earliest iterations of the show it
just showed you how the human mind works
and so I enjoyed the show because it
talked about how something as simple as
a smile before you say something versus
a smile after you say something and how
those change two different it literally
changes the intention of it if you smile
first then say it it seems Sinister but
if you say it to feel Sinister then
smile at the back end it's like ah come
on I'm me like like
it there's a way to kind of yo-yo a
little bit you know and then sometimes
you know be bold and just say what it is
you're thinking and it might be a smile
on the back end it might be something a
little
more like like there was we were talking
about Mike Pence and you know this was a
old this is this was um this is during
when when Daily Show um we were still on
and it was a joke we were thinking about
doing for my guest hosting week wherein
essentially the argument I was trying to
make was
that of all of the current presidential
candidates Mike Pence is the most
confident because he has to get people
who tried to kill him to vote for
him and so that could work on stage but
in the context of television in the
context of structure there are people
who would legitimately believe that what
I'm saying is serious and there are
people who would pull that little bite
and put that up on whatever website and
go roywood Jr endorses Mike Pence and
then on the liberal side there's people
who will see that link or see that
headline not click it and then assume
the worst of me so a lot of it also
comes down to
understanding the medium through which
you're communicating the thing you know
I also think that some of this feels
like because you are are very much not
in in overnight success right it wasn't
like one day you were at an open mic and
the next day you were on The Daily Show
instead you had worked your way up
through clubs you had been on radio you
had been on uh television shows and then
you had this big huge platform you I
feel like one thing that is really true
and I'm curious if it feels like this
for you but you have to me felt like
someone who has a really clear sense of
himself and his voice and what he's
willing to say or not say and I think
that really comes across to an audience
as well does it feel like that to you
internally it does now but it didn't for
like 15 years like you can go back and
watch it's still up online you can go
back and watch my old conen O'Brien sets
from 2011 through 24 there was a stretch
in my career where Conan O'Brien was the
only person who would put me on TV
every other show said no any other show
that I'd already done would not have me
back for whatever reason I'm not talking
trash but facts Conan O'Brien was the
only person who would book me and put me
on television and you can see the
evolution over those three or four those
four or five years of Conan sets and
that was kind of where I started turning
the corner on talking about race
relations in this country and that being
a little bit more of an integral part of
what I wanted to talk about on stage
that's where I probably really started
you know to turn that corner a little
bit and now it's definitely pronounced
it's clear I know what I want to do the
next hour special I want it's about all
of the men other than my father who
influenced me after his death this idea
of manhood and fatherhood and
masculinity and then realizing I have a
plethora of stories some funny some
moving some you know I'm a comedian I
have been very close to Comics that have
killed themselves many of them I know I
knew so this idea of all of these
different life
lessons where did I get those from well
I want to actually talk about some of my
favorite jokes that sound like they're
kind of more in the past from from you
but you know I always think that one of
the the highest compliments that I can
give to a a comedian is that they have a
joke that I think about for the rest of
my life you've changed the way that I
will think about seeing an object or
being in a situation and you have a a
bunch of these you have some of the my
most secondhand described jokes where
we're in a situation and I say oh you
have to watch this Roy Wood Jr joke
about this and one of them is I forever
now anytime I see an oversized American
flag I always think about your
incredible joke about the the the math
of American
flags how many American flags equal a
Confederate
flag there's too many flags in one place
I don't feel comfortable it's so funny
and I just constantly think about you
describing it as like that there's the
residue of racism that too many American
flags you can feel that it has it has a
different message it's not blatantly
racist but I'm watching
you this ISS a lot
it's too many effing Flags yeah but I
mean like a joke like that that just
comes from driving in the South for half
a million miles absolutely I've driven
every freeway in State Road I've seen
the big Garrison Flags when you come
into town and there's something really
good and prideful about it and then I've
also been
in you know some corner store where
there's a bunch of don't tread on me and
all like it's it's interesting it's it's
very interesting and and to me that's
not even and that's a joke where in a
way if you love the flag and you're not
racist how can I thread this so you'll
laugh at it too because this isn't about
your love of the flag this is how when
there's too many flags on the same
street how it makes me feel and I'm not
saying it is racist I'm just saying
this like even the thing we I talked
about in the figure yeah about how I
like the Confederate flag it's I would
rather know where you stand in your
racism than for you to be covert with it
yep that's and it's just a broader
statement about Society I would much
rather it's it's like that it's like the
the the discussion just about you know
down south racism versus upnorth racism
and how it's very polite and up you know
North Northerners are very prejudiced
but it's not in your face where in the
South it's just straight up no stay over
there don't even this is a Sundown town
and I want you to know that like there's
no Northern Sundown towns well it's such
I think it's such a that that joke from
Father Figure is such a perfect way of
getting at something that is really
nuanced about this conversation around
history and symbols right of like that
that you're you're Pro Confederate flag
not because of the memory of the
Confederacy because it lets you know who
feels that way and some formation you
know something that you worked on that
is one of I absolutely love this
documentary you were an executive
producer on uh a documentary called the
neutral ground and and that is made by
this incredible filmmaker CJ hunt and
it's about the fight to remove
Confederate monuments and it looks at a
really serious very sobering issue but
in a hilarious way so I'm curious since
that is so much of you know you have
this family history of being involved in
the Civil Rights struggle and now you
yourself you have this big platform and
you are using it to talk about some of
these same issues so I'd love to to kind
of get into that idea of how humor can
be a way to confront history and why it
might actually be a powerful way to do
that I think it's I think we're past
yelling at each other to get anybody to
understand where you're coming from I
just if the last eight years of politics
have proven nothing more it has proven
that two people screaming at each other
is not going to get anything done you
know we live in our own information
Bubbles as well but you know I think one
of the things that made George Carlin so
amazing was that he could get you to
laugh at something even if you didn't
agree with him and I think that's always
been the same approach so CJ hunt who
who you know directed and made this film
you know CJ and I met at The Daily Show
you know he was a field director and
before that he was working over at Robin
theti so he was already in that grou
groove of looking at humor from The
Rundown with Robin the which was also
like a political satire vehicle over at
bet and so this idea
of if I can get you to laugh at it then
I can get you to
listen and so you want to find jokes
even if they're on yourself or at the if
even if the jokes are at the expense of
yourself and I think the thing that was
very what I respected about CJ's
approach to the neutral ground was that
it didn't come necessarily from a place
of attacking the people who believed and
defended The Monuments it was simply an
exploration into why what is it that
makes you feel this now what if I told
you this this and this about history and
that everything that you've been
everything you've been sold since
reconstruction was propaganda and a lie
the mothers of the Confederacy spun half
of this stuff and got these monuments
like this wasn't even supposed to be
like so
exploring it from that place instead of
chastising people who want to defend all
of that you know and there were still
parts of that documentary that got very
real for CJ you know he went to
Charlottesville and I don't think anyone
predicted that Charlottesville would
have become you know such a lightning
rod point because there have been so
many Charlottesville before just so many
other we're going to show up in protest
and yell at each other from across the
street incidents and Charlottesville was
one that when off the rails and even in
that you sit in the real feelings and
the horror of that and you're still able
to use humor to come out on the other
side and you know I think that you know
for the people that are looking at this
especially like in the professional
sector where you're trying to use humor
and you're trying to use something
light-hearted to go into issues that are
serious within your companies or within
your personal life you don't have to
joke on the issue the issue itself is
not
funny but how did we get here that's
funny the causation who are the people
responsible for the causation or who are
the people that are fighting to change
this there's humor in that who are the
people fighting against change who are
the people fighting for change and I
think if you if you look in those areas
around an issue you're always going to
find fertile ground so you're always
going to find something on the outer
rings that is worthy of satire or
observation and even if it has to wait a
day you wait a day but you know there's
always going to be you know when you
look back you know I look back you know
you know and Trevor Noah had the
unfortunate task of Hosting The Daily
Show pretty much every time an unarmed
cop killing footage got released it was
a show
week and so you know
this idea
of figuring out where the humor is in
that and the humor is not in the tragedy
it's in the bureaucracy around it so I
just think when you look at it that way
then you're able to find Pockets where
you can you know you can you can jab a
joke real quick and get in and get out
it doesn't have to be hilarious all the
way through but you definitely want as
best you can to try and use humor I just
think it's I just think it's a better
way you know of doing things so
for people who are listening who you
know they they see the power of humor
they see the power of Comedy but they're
not professional comedians that they
don't necessarily think of themselves
that way what tips would you give them
for trying to successfully land a joke
without offending people I think if it's
about trying to find humor without
offending I I don't think that that
place truly exists I think that you can
try to make it as offense proof as
possible so the first thing you have to
do is let go of the fact that someone is
is or isn't going to be offended um or
you delve in the four as I call it the
four the four safety Corners like food
is never offending it not to the point
of War maybe on Twitter if I if I go on
Twitter and go I hate this food then a
bunch of people
but you can still show up to work the
next day you're not going to get sent to
HR because you said you didn't like
macaroni with breadcrumbs which by the
way is not the way to do macaroni please
stop putting breadcrumbs in macaroni and
stop truffling everything I'm getting
off top oh people are oh the the
comments are going off right now people
are Furious about I see the Emojis
floating up stop truffling everything I
said it it's there's no reason
everything doesn't have to taste like a
fart only pasta so if you're not
attacking a person or an ideology or a
group of people you're generally in a
safe place um if you are not attacking a
particular reason why something happened
um
also don't make jokes based on
assumptions of the truth of why you
think someone did something because what
we also live in is a correction culture
and so people are quick to go well you
know the reason why that actually
happened so if you go he did that
because this and joke well someone who
doesn't believe that premise you know
mik bigle has said it best everybody has
to agree on the premise before we'll
agree on to laugh at the punchline and I
think that's what we've we've lost as of
late but if we're just talking short
fire short answer rapid fire food
entertainment love and money like job
employment if you stay in those four
pockets it's going to be hard to offend
someone but if you're if you're
determined to make the EDG of your joke
just know that somebody might not like
it especially if it's at the expense of
another group well a lot of people in
the in the um audience here are asking
some version of this question this is
one of the most common things that
people want to know about comedy these
days I find it's like but what aren't
you afraid of being canceled aren't you
afraid of what what will happen if
people take it the wrong way so how do
you how do you think about that I don't
think about jokes being taken the wrong
way I can't concern myself with that my
job is to write the joke that I think is
funny and perform it for the people
people who want to laugh now I exist in
a different space because I'm not at a
company where I can be written up I
can't go I can't be sent to HR at a
comedy club all that happens is that
people either show up or they don't show
up and at the end of the day I think
that people vote with their wallets and
their remote controls and so if there's
people that still love you they're going
to come see you and so those are the
people that you do it for and you
ultimately cannot if you're constantly
performing
to not piss off a group of people then
who are you because now you're
constantly altering yourself to public
ideologies and to me that's a very
dangerous and uncreative place to be
because now you're trying to
be creatively aloc cart for whatever the
moods are at that particular time and if
you're that then at what point are you
ever yourself the the thing though that
I wonder about is how do you balance the
authenticity and the courage to say
something that you believe in regardless
of consequences with the ability to stay
open to valid critiques about places
where you're getting it wrong or you
haven't thought it through all the way
because it seems like a lot of times
people take any criticism as an attack
and shutting it down rather than an
opportunity to grow so how do you
balance those Nuance has been removed
from the from the conversation you know
I've always welcomed you know critique
and criticism but then critique and
criticism also has to come from a place
of not trying to completely chop
somebody's head off and I think I I'm
one of the few comedians that reads
their YouTube comments I know you
shouldn't but YouTube and Reddit are by
far the most comprehensive and fair
critiques of any forms of entertainment
in my
opinion better than Facebook better than
Twitter all of that because like Twitter
and Facebook like that's all engagement
and arguing in the comments like it's
performative I consider that outrage
performative whereas if you're typing a
Reddit thread you don't know who's gonna
see this it might only four people might
see this or or a million like that's
from the heart um I just I just don't
think that you
can I don't think that you can truly say
you evolving as a
performer if you're not looking at how
some of the material is making people
feel whether you adjust to it or not is
up to you but what I do not like is the
retroactive cancellation of oh here's
something that you said from 15 years
ago at a time where Society was
different and I will judge it now based
on current societal standards and attack
you as if you just said it
yesterday that I'm not cool with
I I think that's a little bit of
a if we want to acknowledge the past and
apologize and get past it cool but
totally and also you know any good
performer any person that you want to
spend time with hopefully they've grown
and changed and improve you know and I
think that's part of that should be part
of that assessment when you find the old
clip on person let's also take a look at
their Arc from that time until now uh
but I do think that jokes have real
effects like I I think it's it's naive
to think that you can make a joke and
speak truth to power and and and
establishment and the the government
will change with this joke and then also
not think that you can write a joke that
could destroy somebody and make them
feel inhumane you know we've been
talking about how it's important to have
a thick skin to be a comic and yet many
artists and many creative people are
really sensitive and that's that's key
to tapping into their creativity so what
advice do you have for people who are
artists or creative people who want to
be more comfortable getting that
feedback who want to get to the place
where maybe they could read their RIT
comments or their YouTube comments but
but they feel like they they aren't
there yet find a person you love and
read their YouTube
comments and see the hate and see and
just you're literally you're going to be
amazed at how could someone not like
that project or that movie what's a
movie you love go read some reviews it's
all got haters and once you see that
it'll help normalize it a little bit for
you and you'll know that what you were
doing is not that different and that's
just all part of the path you know I
know some people don't like hate and
it's also very different for women which
is something that I learned from talking
with a lot of you know with a lot of uh
women comics in the industry that is you
know what I've benefited from is that
most any insult that I filled it has
been a critique of my
art it wasn't a death threat it wasn't
my looks it was you know things of that
nature so you know by all means I
wouldn't say immerse yourself into
anything that's triggering or your own
traumas but if you can as best you can
look and assess the things that you love
and just see that none of it is
unfailable it all gets insulted it all
gets critiqued by people who can't do it
who don't know what they're doing and
once you understand that that's part of
the process then you're able to trust
what you're doing and just find your
audience find the people who like you
that's all you got to
do well let's let's go and talk about
the the White House correspondence
dinner for a second because you hosted
it this year and you know this is you're
directly talking to the most powerful
people in the country and I'm curious
what jokes you were proudest of that you
got to say
in that setting I had like you know six
or seven writers working with me on this
um former Daily Show former nightly show
you know all all worth their weight in
the political satire sphere and we
were constantly changing everything like
we man I had a whole five minute spy
balloon chunk and by the time we got to
the dinner no one cared about spy
balloons anymore like it was just such a
we made so we made it a throwaway joke
and it worked but the Clarence Thomas
nft joke still makes me laugh and saying
that we can see him but he's owned by
someone else and that's what an nft
is
um which you know considering that
people call Clarence Thomas a token
black guy and nft also means token and
they thought that I was also that was
like a happy accident where people were
like oh yeah you called him a token like
nft a token I was like yes yes I did
absolutely that was the intention when
mhm you caught that well Roy it's been
such a pleasure talking to you thank you
so much and and congratulations on all
of your degrees it's really impressive
well yes thank you I worked very hard at
them with
[Music]
sharpies